will anybody hold him accountable for
what he did
back in the day in his utter failure to
bring us together as a nation
despite his repeated promises to do so
and again what about that 1994
crime bill a white house reporter did
ask press secretary jen saki about that
yesterday and the fact that
a harvard professor and civil rights
activist named cornell west you may have
heard of him
said that biden is quote one of the core
architects
of mass incarceration the killing of 16
year old mikayla bryant by the columbus
police is tragic she was a child
we're thinking of her friends and family
in the communities that are hurting and
grieving her loss
we know that police violence just
proportionally impacts
black and latino people in communities
and that black women and girls like
black men and boys
experience higher rates of police
violence well gensake was asked
again specifically you know if there was
a situation where joe biden felt some
sort of accountability for his role
in that 1994 crime bill you know
everybody seems to be talking about
accountability these days but no one
seems to want to accept
accountability including joe biden let's
welcome in now host of the reuben report
dave rubin
talk more about this he is the author of
don't burn this book thinking for
yourself in an
age of unreason dave great to see you
good to be with you johnny do you know
real quick before i even let you get to
the first question
uh you said something about truth right
up at the top that we can't agree on
truth i just want to completely go on
the record that everything that you just
said there
was truthful and i would be happy to go
into any of the statistics to back that
up as we
talk right now yeah i mean i really
wanted to play that exchange between
jen saki and the reporter yesterday you
know because we have the clip two of joe
biden from 1994
talking about irredeemable kids as
predators and things like that and on
the floor of the u.s senate and
you know yes we may have caused these
problems as a society but that doesn't
mean we can't lock them up and throw
away the key forever
you know joe biden is one of the people
most responsible
for this institutional racism we hear so
much about
and again he nor lebron james nor anyone
else wants to take
accountability or they want to hear it
well let's be very clear joe biden has
been
in the government for 47 years did he
forget
for the first 47 to do anything about
any of this stuff did
why didn't he solve racism for 47 years
he was also
if and correct me if i'm wrong on this i
know you guys have fact checkers i think
he was vice president
under a black president
why did he and that guy not do anything
about any of this and by the way
barack obama issued a statement the last
couple days on twitter that further fan
the flames on all of this stuff
the sick truth related to this this
knife incident
is that if she had killed the other girl
nobody would be talking about this
nobody would be talking about an
absolutely innocent girl being maimed to
death
by a knife-wielding maniac now all of us
would prefer that there were less
lethal incidences related to person on
person crime you know citizen on citizen
or
or policing but there are no perfect
systems and if your answer is that that
cop
should have done something else somehow
or maybe used a taser which could or
couldn't have worked
or is harder to aim or whatever it might
be well then that girl is most likely
dead and no one would have cared and
lebron wouldn't have said anything
and by the way quickly on the lebron
front um although what he has
said has been completely ridiculous at
some level i do
sort of pity with him because he has
been thrown
into this thing and yes it's his choice
to defend china at all costs and always
attack the united states
but it's just so profoundly obvious that
he doesn't know what he's talking about
and i even retweeted his tweet that you
showed there uh yesterday
and i used actual statistics from the
washington post they're supposedly
a trustworthy organization and in 2019
nine unarmed black people were shot and
killed by cops and
19 unarmed white people so when he's
talking about this endless assault on
black people
it just isn't true but this goes to your
your first point which is that the truth
in many ways doesn't matter to these
people and that's what we have to figure
out how to deal with
yeah and it's it's a it's amazing to me
and maybe i'm just stupid and naive dave
but i wanted to believe that we could
come back together that maybe that joe
biden would you know
hold off against some of these you know
pushes from the far left progresses but
he seems to
be completely steamrolled by that wing
of the democratic party
i don't know if it's steamrolled or he
just stands for nothing anymore or he's
cognitively not
able to stand up for whatever it is that
we sort of thought he believed as
as somewhat of a centrist i think that's
all up for debate and maybe years from
now we'll be able to find out something
closer to the truth
on that but for any of my liberal
friends
you know the the sort of sane liberals
that once existed
for any of them that thought he was
going to be the guy to stop the
craziness it's like
guys it's time for your maya culpa every
single bad
idea that the left has is being ushered
into the
united states government right now
they're bringing critical race theory
back in schools i mean if you are a
parent at this point and you send your
children to a public school voluntarily
you have to really think about that now
i get not everybody has the means to do
that and by the way that's why there's a
massive movement growing on the right
that we should fund students not schools
right which i'm completely for that way
you have school choice which by the way
is one of the things that the
progressives don't want you know
elizabeth warren
hates charter schools you're not going
to believe it john where does she send
her
own children yeah they went to private
of course they all send their kids to
private schools and this is why we
advocate for school choice and giving
parents more
you know ability to make decisions where
they want to send their school if you
give them either
tax breaks or vouchers or give them the
money that you give schools
they will be more empowered we do have
those statistics which you can put up on
the screen again we've been showing
those dave you referenced those here
this is these are the facts
from the washington post of all places
on what the you know
police involved shootings are of unarmed
people here over the last three years
again these are all facts they
this is so confounding because
you see this data on the screen but yet
so many in the media so many democrats
continue to perpetuate the lie
that this disproportionately affects
black people
i mean in essence there is a movement to
destroy america right now i know that
sounds sort of alarmist at
one level but i think we can only fix
this thing if we call it what it is and
and don't take my word for it
what was aoc saying right after the
verdict that she wanted
in the george floyd case just a few days
ago immediately this is just the
beginning right
what was nancy pelosi i mean in a truly
psychotic oh my god media let her skate
over
thank you george floyd thank you i mean
she literally thanked him for dying i'm
fairly certain he would prefer to be
alive right now
but they are using yeah they were they
are using
everything that they can grab as a
crudgeal to
destroy the foundations of america and
what i'm trying to figure out and i know
you're trying as well john
is who will stand up for america at this
point yeah there are a couple people
they're doing it pretty well in your
state and you're great governor ron
desantis
but who really from the intellectual
elite who from
from the uh
cornell west too because you know he
pointed out yesterday as i think some
people smartly did i mean this
verdict is no reason to to celebrate
there's no need to break dance from
from one guilty verdict here there is a
lack of i think education
understanding of what the core issues
are uh and it's
it's being distorted every day but dave
you do your part we try to do ours here
always great to see you on thursday
we'll talk soon thanks so much good to
see you john if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell